Freud believed that the fundamental
myths of the human being was the eatable
myth and the Eden Poe myths from a
broader perspective is a failed hero's
story so the eatable myth is the myth of
a man who develops who grows up but then
accidentally becomes too close to his
mother sleeps with her
he doesn't know who she is and as a
consequence blinds himself and there's a
there's a there's a warning about human
development gone wrong in that story and
I think that Freud put his finger on it
extraordinarily well because human
beings have a very long period of
dependency and one of the things that
you do see in clinical practice is that
many people's problems are associated
with their inability to break free of
their family like they're consumed by
the family drama right they can't get
beyond what happened to them in their
family they're stuck in the past it's
and that's that's equivalent
symbolically speaking you might say to
the idea of being too close to your
mother of the boundaries being
improperly specified and that happens
far more often than anyone would like to
think as I said for I thought it was a
universal but you see he had a different
idea and his idea was that it wasn't the
failed hero story that was the universal
human myth it was the successful heroes
story and that's a big difference like
it's seriously a big difference because
the successful hero's story is
remembering Sleeping Beauty you may
remember this in the Disney movie the
Evil Queen traps the prince in a dungeon
and she's not going to let him out till
he's old right and so there's this
comical scene where she's down in the
dungeon he's all in Chains and she's
laughing at him telling him what his
future is going to be like she's quite
evil and you know she paints this
wonderful picture of him being freed in
like 80 years and hobbling out of the
castle on his his horse that's so old it
can barely stand up in him with grey
heron and you know she and she recites
the story of his eventual triumphant
departure from the castle as a old inn
creping man and she has a great laugh
about it and it's nice you know it's a
real punchy sir it's really something
wonderful for children that's story and
he gets free of the of the shackles and
the things that free em are three little
female fairies it's the positive aspect
of the feminine that frees him from the
dungeon so it's very interesting and
very accurate from a psychological
perspective it's the negative element of
the feminine that encapsulate him in the
dungeon and supposed of element of the
feminine would freeze him and and then
he has a the Queen the evil queen is not
very happy when he escapes you may
remember that she stands on top of her
castle tower and starts to spin off
cosmic sparks I mean she's quite the
creature enveloped in flame and then she
turns into a dragon and she then the
prince has to fight with her in order to
make contact with Sleeping Beauty and
and a Lincoln her from her comatose
existence as her unconscious existence
and that's a brilliant it's a brilliant
representation of the successful hero
myth he he doesn't end up staying in an
unholy relationship with his mother
let's say he escapes and then conquers
the worst thing that can be imagined and
is noble by that and not as a
consequence he's able to wake the
slumbering feminine from its coma and
that's a union story and that's the
story that he juxtaposed against Freud
see Freud thought of religious phenomena
as part of an occult tide that would be
it would drown rational rationality
that's why Freud was so dominant Lee
anti-religious and you thought no it's
not the case you're throwing the baby
out with the bathwater there's something
profound and central to the hero myth
and Jung Yin clinical work is
essentially the awakening of the hero
myth in the analysand in the in the
client or the patient
to conceptualize yourself as that which
can confront chaos and triumph and that
that's associated with an ennobling of
the of consciousness and the
establishment of proper positive
relationships between male and female
and you know I'm a skeptical person I'm
a very very skeptical person and I've
tried with every trick I have to put a
lever underneath young story and lift it
up and and disrupt it and I I can't do
it I think he was right and that Freud
was wrong I mean I have great respect
for Freud I think he got the program
problem diagnosed very very nicely and
in my clinical work I see the phenomena
that Freud described emerged continually
constantly that the best if you're
interested in that there's a documentary
you should watch I may have mentioned it
before I think it's the best documentary
ever made certainly the best one I've
ever seen
it's called crumb and it's about an
underground cartoonist Robert Crumb who
who was part of a hippy movement and
although he hated hippies he was part of
the hippy movement in the 60s in San
Francisco and started the entire
underground comic what culture that
manifested itself eventually in in
graphic novels there's quite a
significant figure from the perspective
of popular art and a very very
intelligent man and also I would say a
hero although a very bent and depraved
and warped one someone very acutely
aware of his own shadow and the
documentary outlines his attempts to
escape from his absolutely dreadful
mother and the failure of his two
brothers to do the same thing
one of whom ended up as a street beggar
in San Francisco the other who drank
furniture polish and died six months
after the documentary was produced it's
an unbelievably shocking documentary
it's the only piece of film that I've
ever seen that captures Freudian
pathology I've never seen anything
because you can't see it generally
unless you're in a clinical situation
unless you know the details of someone's
lives the personal intimate details you
cannot communicate it
but the
documentaries who made the film with
Roberts leg off if I remember correctly
was a friend of the crumbs and so he got
access in a way that no one else would
have and they were also very forthright
and forthcoming about their situation in
general I would highly recommend that
it's it's a real punch if you want to
know how a rapist thinks like if you
actually want to know because maybe you
don't want to know in fact you probably
don't want to know
right because do you really want to know
that because I understand that means to
put yourself in that position and to
understand it if you really want to know
how a serial sexual predator thinks and
why if you watch crumb and you pay
attention you'll know and that's only a
tiny bit of what the film has to offer
it's really quite remarkable